welcome to my video series of mole bio
explaining 3 minutes where I explain a
concept in biology in less than three
minutes if you haven't yet subscribed to
my channel
hit that subscribe button these videos
are not so long and detailed but it has
all the necessary information to save
your ass before the day of your exam so
let's start so today's video we will
talk about the Quino fragment which is a
large portion of the DNA polymerase 1
and it's a day to day 2 used in
molecular biology labs so if you
remember the replication process in
e.coli then we can understand the DNA
polymerase one has a primer removal
activity and the primary removal of the
activity of the DNA polymerase 1 is
based on its 5 prime to 3 prime
exonuclease activity the forward
exonuclease activity now let us look at
the DNA polymer is one structure to
understand the Queen of fragment the
structure of the Kerner fragment we need
to understand it so DNA polymerase 1 has
three fundamental domains first domain
is a polymerization domain which helps
in polymerizing in a 5 prime to 3 prime
direction the second domain is the
exonuclease domain which has a
exonuclease activity in 3 prime to 5
prime that helps in proofreading and the
last domain is the forward exonuclease
domain which has a 5 prime to 3 prime
exonuclease activity and this is helpful
for primer removal now tn a polymer is
one can be digested with subtly sin and
that results a large fragment of the
beginner ball one which is known as
cleaner fragment and thus queen of
fragment lacks one domain which is the 5
prime to 3 prime exonuclease activity
continuing to main now getting rid of
these forward eggs a nucleus activity
make the cleaner fragment very useful in
multiple usage in the molecular biology
field so among many other usage the
principal usage of cleaner fragment is
synthesizing double-stranded DNA from
single-stranded templates it's specially
used in blunt end cloning so filling the
5-prime and 3-prime overhangs is a one
of the important use of it creating
level
radioactive probes is another important
use and then I made multiple other
different use of cleaner fragment so
let's talk about how it could be used to
create a radio label Pro so while the
cleaner fragment is progressing in a
five prime to three prime direction it
has its polymerize activity and at that
time if you put label nucleotide it will
incorporate that into the DNA and later
it could be used to create label probes
after that blanton cloning is an
important usage of kala fragment so many
of the cases what happens is we have our
vector which is cut with a restriction
enzyme which create plant ends but our
DNA of interest is cut with a
restriction and no nucleus which creates
a sticky end and has three prime or Phi
prime overhangs but these are two
incompatible to each other right in
order for them to be cloned into this
particular vector treated with blunt end
these inserts also need to be blunt
somehow right and in that regard we know
fragment comes very handy so what would
happen is the cleaner fragment would sit
in the three prime or five prime blunt
ends and it has a 3 prime to 5 prime
exonuclease activity right so it would
chop off the three prime overhangs
and in case of Phi prime overhang it
would sit there and it has the five
prime to three prime polymerize activity
which would fill the gaps both the cases
be chopping off the three prime overhang
or filling in the gap in the five prime
overhang both would create planted
products and these these blunted inserts
could be incorporated into the plant
vectors and that is how the cloning the
further steps of the cloning can be
proceeded with right so these are two of
useful in usage of Queen o fragment but
there are many other usage which I'm not
talking about in this video I hope you
enjoyed this video if you give it if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you
you